and we've got some breaking news now out
of Berlin Germany has finally agreed to
allow leopard to tanks to be sent to
Ukraine and has also approved their
re-export from partner countries let's
bring in Dominic Kane who's live for us
in Berlin and has more on these
developments Dominic what happens now
tell us talk us through the timeline
well what happens now is everyone says
why has it taken Germany so long to do
this where do we go from here what we
know is a company of leopard two tanks
that's 14 leopard two tanks will be in
the first Trash as it were the first
slice of resources sent to Ukraine
that's from the German perspective but
then also this idea of the re-exports
being allowed or the Polish government
The Finnish government and others had
been calling and it did the Czech
foreign minister yesterday calling on
the Germans to release the tanks being
held by other countries remember that
there are very many Leopard 2 tanks that
were sold from Germany to other EU NATO
countries and those are the countries
who were beseeching all our shots to do
what he has now done so the theory is
that there will be at some point almost
a battalion of Tanks now that's several
companies of which obviously one is
going to be German and that we know some
people suggesting around 90 tanks from
all around Europe Europe will be sent to
Ukraine remember also that we know that
the United States government is talking
about the sending M1 Abrams tanks and
the United Kingdom is sending 14
Challenger 2 tanks another company of
Tanks so it looks as though in the
course of the next few weeks months
these deliveries will take place but
remember that the people who will be
using them in Ukraine will need to be
trained how to use them all right we
really appreciate that update Dominic
Kane lab for us there in Berlin thank
you